an independent autopsy requested by
george floyd's family will be released
today
according to the family's attorney the
medical examiner in minneapolis found
the combined effects of being restrained
possible intoxicants and underlying
health issues
all likely contributed to his death
jamie yukas is at the memorial for floyd
in minneapolis jamie good morning
anthony good morning the floyd family
and their attorney released a statement
saying
they reject the notion that the knee
from the police officer on george's neck
for almost nine minutes was not the
proximate cause of his death
they want derrick chavin to be charged
with first degree murder
the former minneapolis police officer
was charged friday with third degree
murder and second degree manslaughter
for floyd's death
according to police documents chavin had
18
complaints filed against him in his
nearly two decades with the department
16 of them were resolved without
discipline new video appears to show the
officers struggling with someone
inside a police vehicle before floyd's
death floyd does not appear in the
apparent surveillance video
the video has not been independently
verified by cbs news
minnesota's attorney general keith
ellison and hennepin county attorney
mike freeman announced yesterday
a joint effort on this case it came
after criticism freeman waited too long
to bring charges and does not have the
public's trust chavvin's expected in
court june 8.
ellison suggests the other three
officers may be charged and additional
charges
may be filed against chavin gayle
thank you jamie